we all got into it because we have
killer taste and we also felt like we
can do
this
xyz thing
and then we start to create it
and we realize there's this gap between
what we're creating and what we like
when did you begin to realize that if
you poured all of your energy and
passion into your art that one day
someone would give you a job
when did i realize
or that you'd be discovered yeah
you know that's a real that's an
interesting question because
it comes down to the definition of the
word discovered
you know what does discovered mean
i would say that i as a kid and i think
probably every filmmaker watching this
probably feels this way
you look at
whatever raiders of the lost ark and you
go i could do that
i wonder if anyone else believes i can
do that like it's i know i have to
convince the world that i can actually
do it
now in my case
the people that
have
believed in me and given me the shot
have not been the people i expected so
uh
it was
came it'd be like a best friend who just
happened to be in a position that they
hire me and it just like came from back
here and you're like wait what you're
gonna
that's when
i was ho i it was like it was one of
those things where i always felt like i
had something to contribute something to
give
i was just wondering how long it was
going to take for anyone to actually
notice you know what i mean it's almost
the other way around it's like i always
but i think we're all that way we all
feel that way we all feel like we have
something special and you're just
waiting for the world to catch up to
where we are
that can be a frustrating
position especially if you feel like no
one's discovered you yet but um
i have always found that when it does
happen
and no matter which level you're on it
does happen and that that could mean
a movie deal or it could mean getting a
nice job
you know dragging a commercial
it always comes from the last place i
expected usually a friend or a contact
of some sort
yeah so
yeah and i think
that yeah it comes down to that
maddening place of
how long is it going to take for
everyone else to discover what i can do
this is where and this is where it's so
important to
continue to create and put out there
stuff that you
can do
there's a great quote from ira glass
who is the host of or the creator of
this american life and he talks about
how when we got into
the art whatever it is that we got into
um
we all got into it because we have
killer taste and we also felt like we
can do
this xyz thing um and then we start to
create it
and we realize there's this gap between
what we're creating and what we like
and we see that gap because we have good
taste and the only way to close that gap
is to continue to create work
lots of work
thousands of hours
and that's the only way to close that
gap and if you find yourself not
creating anything and and you're in this
business just toiling away editing
reality television for years and years
and years and never actually making
anything then you should probably you're
never going to close that gap unless you
do it
that is how people will discover you
because the more you do it the better
you're going to get
and eventually live averages says that
that is what will happen
come back and ask me in a year and we'll
see you know and spielberg is called
nash
we'll see if that actually pays off but
um
that's how it's worked so far
do you think the notion of being
discovered is is
sort of an old term you know i'm sort of
thinking of you know like a talent show
from the 80s where
you're going to be picked and you're
going places kid but it almost seems
like now
they want to see how much work of your
own have you put in
without someone picking you
it seems like things have changed a lot
there has been a change well the one
thing that's changed i think is that
um
the ability to create amazing stuff is
is has come down to
other levels where you can reach it
because you know back in the day
to create anything that looked any good
you'd have to rent these really
expensive cameras and big lights and
stuff you don't have to do that anymore
i mean it's just the way iphone shoot
looks amazing like really amazing so
there is still i think the divide
between
the the threshold of
television movies you know working with
disney on a thing that people have heard
of there is that little divide so that
still exists
and there's there's that stuff and then
there's everything else
but
there is still so much amazing work out
there to be had you know they're still
and you can be i the discovery can
happen on those other little projects um
and that is i think it's uh
really fun to do it because
like for example i do a lot of work with
hospitals and hospitals a lot of times
hire me to create these little stories
and i'm telling you they are so much fun
to do because they're little
short films that are usually really
meaningful really heartfelt you're
working with actors
and and it is you're making a little
movie you get great practice
and it is super super fun
uh and i was discovered
from that based on you know people that
i knew and and just doing little shorts
of my own like they would they would see
a little short film or whatever it hits
a festival or something and then they go
we should hire that guy to bring do our
little thing that's how all that stuff
happened so you could call that a
discovery now is it gonna win an academy
award no
but that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that i'm i'm
doing what i dreamed of doing as a kid
and it is a blast
and you know
people may watch this and go oh that
guy's never
made a multi-million dollar thing okay
you're right i haven't
but i'm having a freaking great time
making and telling stories and moving
people it is it is
just it is the most fun career
that you can have because
you're telling stories and you're
taking audiences on a ride
no matter where you're doing it whether
that's
a wedding video or completely on the
opposite end with a marvel film you're
doing the same job and it is really
great so yeah it's uh
i don't know if that answered your
original question about being discovered
but i do think that there is a
when they're trusting you with
telling the story for their brand or for
their whatever
uh
there is a discovery process that does
need to happen they need to see that you
have the talent to actually manipulate
and tell a story and craft a narrative
in a way that wraps up
what they're trying to sell or do or say
right
so hence the
sort of corporate video that was in um
jurassic park
i think also in blade runner too didn't
they have a few like they'd have these
billboards
yeah these commercials well that's right
i mean most times when you see a sci-fi
act yes stuff like that fantasy they'll
have some sort of way to communicate
information um
that's that's corporate video one-on-one
right there
and
heck
what better way to practice you know if
you are gonna
let's just say you could look at your
life from beginning to end and you knew
that in
i don't know 10 years you were going to
get to direct the next blade runner
well
wouldn't it be good to practice and you
know that in that blade runner there's
going to be a whole time travel element
that you're going to have to fold into
it and explain to an audience how it
works wouldn't it be good to like kind
of practice that now
with your with att client that you have
or or whatever you know like wouldn't it
be good to like kind of maybe
because if you mess that up who cares
you know it's just the corporate video
that not a lot of people are gonna see
wouldn't that be much better to do it
that way and then by the time you get to
blade runner sequel
oh man i got this i've been doing this
this is going to be fun and now i have
all the money to do it like that's a
great way to look at it you know why did
you see the apple commercial around
1984. it's just the one where they throw
the thing into the screen yes i think so
right directed by ridley scott
yeah
that
that apple commercial
isn't that crazy it has this amazing
look this really cool story
it never it aired one time on television
i believe this is pre-internet
and it made so many ripples and it
really made ridley scott's career like
from there he went on and did i think i
think alien was after that
he might have done the duelist at that
point but yeah that was because really
scott was a commercial director before
he became
doing movies
so